la ministre des armées florence parly
s'est rendu au lycée militaire de saint
cyr l'école
objectif de la rencontre faire un point
sur les investissements pour
l'établissement mais aussi sur cette
rentrée si particulière c'est annulé
particulière parce que l'environnement
sanitaire est fragile mais le lycée
militaire a tout mis en oeuvre pour
accueillir ses élèves
tout est mis en oeuvre au niveau
sanitaire je parle bien sûr du port du
masque obligatoire au quotidien la
ministre des armées a profité de sa
visite pour annoncer officiellement le
nouveau nom de l'établissement il
s'appellera désormais lycée militaire de
gaulle de saint cyr l'école
nous avons pensé que c'était le bon
moment pour que le lycée de saint cyr
l'école porte aussi le nom du général de
gaulle et c'est donc en accord avec le
chef d'état major de l'armée de terre
que nous avons annoncé cet après midi
que le lycée militaire s'appellerait
lycée militaire de gaulle de saint cyr
l'école
autre nouveauté les 22 millions d'euros
d'investissements prévus à saint cyr
l'école
un projet qui s'inscrit dans le cadre du
plan lycée objectif rénover les locaux
devenus vétustes et un bâtiment
modulaire qui actuellement est en
construction qui accueillera sur les
deux années à venir et classes
préparatoires le temps que leur bâtiment
soit rénové et ainsi à la fin de cette
rénovation
ce bâtiment sera transformé en salle de
cours le premier investissement qui est
ici qui sera occupé dès qu'il sera
terminé c'est-à-dire mois de janvier
2021 et ensuite des travaux démarreront
dans les bâtiments qui le nécessitent
le bâtiment l'as salé et ensuite le
bâtiment de tom morel
au total ce sont près de 800 élèves qui
ont fait leur rentrée au lycée militaire
de saint cyr l'école début septembre